nous allons revoir cette même scène
filmée sous un autre angle afin de mieux
comprendre ce qui s'est passé comme vous
l'avez compris tout se déroule dans la
banlieue du caire où chaque année une
parade défilent devant le chef de l'état
son gouvernement et les corps constitués
et puis tout à coup c'est le drame
lorsque surgissant d'un engin motorisé
un groupe de soldats mais pied-à-terre
se précipite vers la tribune
en ouvrant le feu héliopolis 13 heures
défilé militaire pour le huitième
anniversaire de la guerre du kippour les
unités blindées passe devant la tribune
présidentielle
les mirage quand un passage dans un
bruit assourdissant
à ce moment on entend des tirs un camion
militaire s'est arrêté devant la tribune
six hommes sont à terre un homme jette
une grenade tirs d'armes automatiques
sur l'assistance les fusionne va durer 2
minutes
la garde présidentielle riposte deux
soldats à l'origine de l'attentât sont
tués
regardez cet homme il prend son temps et
ajuste son tir
le président sadate et toucher de balle
au côté droit et au bras
le caméraman américain se protège
derrière le mur de la tribune mais il
continue et film
dans la tribune freixa sont renversés
sous l'effet des explosions et des tirs
les personnalités sont à terre certains
blessés dont tu es dans la confusion la
plus extrême et les hurlements de la
foule on relève des blessés pour les
évacuer le général nabil fesses de chef
d'état major de l'armée égyptienne est
tué le secrétaire particulier du chef de
l'état et son photographe sont également
tués
et voilà
le toit
bakou
pourquoi
[Musique]
parmi les blessés l'ambassadeur de
belgique au caire le ministre de la
défense égyptien et des invités
d'honneur
trois militaires américains sont touchés
le vice président monsieur moubarak et
mais légèrement blessé
cet homme dans la tribune visage contre
terre peut-être le président sadate
l'attentât a été revendiqué à beyrouth
par une mystérieuse organisation de
libération égyptienne indépendante
[Musique]